ahora muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español hoy nos acompaña
ángel y giovani hoyos cineasta
colombiano nacionalizado en argentina es
el director del documental marea verde
en el cual recorre la lucha por el
aborto legal el argentina y lo hace a
través de las voces de sus propias
protagonistas ángel muchísimas gracias
por tu presencia en la entrevista de
france 24 en español
hola muchas gracias por la invitación la
verdad que ha cantado un honor estar en
un espacio que le das voces a la
libertad a la igualdad y en búsqueda de
un mundo un poquito menos peor que
brinda palabra muchísimas gracias a
hojas que él por estas palabras bueno
comencemos cuando te preguntan por qué
hiciste marea verde decís que por tu
madre nos contaría si esa parte de tu
historia que fue el puntapié no por lo
que comentaba en este documental tan
interesante
a ese extenso que soy un eterno
adolescente y siempre la culpable de
todo va a ser mi mamá
mira yo creo que a mí lo que más me
impactó inicialmente fue la imagen de
las mujeres argentinas reclamando aborto
legal en las calles y eso hizo que en mi
memoria esa memoria recordará un
episodio de mi adolescencia en los que a
los 15 años mi madre me confesaba su
aborto en medio de lágrimas y vergüenza
yo tengo que realmente confesarles que
yo en ese momento a mí no me interesaba
no quería escucharla porque tampoco
sabía del tema y eso y ese detonante fue
lo que hizo que esa imagen me
sensibilizará
y durante seis años siguiera activistas
que que reclamaban el derecho al aborto
legal seguro y gratuito
creo que es un conjunto de coincidencias
y experiencias desde mi adolescencia de
los 15 años
o sea que claro creciste no con esa
suerte de activismo al menos de alguna
manera inconsciente quizás ángel ahora
marea verde tuvo su première mundial en
la competencia oficial de cine de
varsovia estuvo en festivales a lo largo
de todo el mundo en distintos
continentes en estados unidos en italia
paraguay méxico uruguay como fue la
recepción en el exterior que pudiste
percibir
bueno la verdad que por ejemplo en el
caso del festival de varsovia se estrenó
en polonia
una sala a poco aforo es mucho barbijo
pero sobre todo con una
europa del norte donde los el avance de
la derecha empezó a volver a penalizar
el aborto entonces el director del
festival invitó a la película con mucho
cariño y con una necesidad de que
inspirará
estas mujeres estas activistas europeas
a tomar nuevas herramientas de activismo
como lo que fue después en méxico fue
muy abrazada también o sea yo te diría
que es polonia méxico y estados unidos
quienes ha prestado mucha atención a la
película y volviendo a mi madre el
estreno el primer estreno en salas
prefestivales fue en bogotá colombia y
cuando se encienden las salas de la tv
de la sala de cine de bogotá de la
cinemateca de bogotá está en primera
fila mi mamá y mi abuela en los martes
ya de lágrimas y
y ahí yo ya cumplí es como
él le puede es como una especie de
regalo el universo puede dedicar a mi
mamá la película de esta forma y fue muy
bien recepción a la recepción ha sido de
esa manera muy cálida muy inesperada
porque es una película muy emocional no
vi ver a pasar frío pasa sino alegrías
no absolutamente y es realmente
conmovedor ver cómo atraviesa no sólo la
historia de un país de una región sino
tu propia historia
ángel bueno un tema sobre el que te han
preguntado bastante no y qué bueno no
puedo evitar tienen que ver con cómo te
interpela esta lucha como hombre decís
vos dijiste en alguna oportunidad que la
pregunta sobre vos mismo llegó con el
intercambio con las crisis sociales y
también con el público no una vez que
vio la luz el documental qué pasó cuando
surgió esa pregunta qué reflexiones te
llevo
estoy reflexionando de melazas de nuevo
y no tengo una respuesta formada porque
yo no hubiera hecho la película si
hubiera sido si hubiera estado tan
presente esa ese interrogante si la
respuesta está en que las activistas
actriz social las actrices sociales que
yo filmo estuvieron siempre abiertas a
que yo la siguiera a compartir me en sus
conocimientos sus experiencias sobre
todo no entonces pienso que en ese
sentido la discusión es una discusión
colectiva
porque a partir de eso es donde nosotros
podemos decir qué temas de qué temas
corresponden o qué temas no corresponden
por un rango etario por una en una
reconocimiento sexual por una
nacionalidad toca y quién no toca ahí es
donde yo digo que el punto de vista como
se narra y lo que finalmente se cuenta
es lo más importante no siempre y cuando
bueno tengas aprobación de quién firma
no de quién registras porque eso es un
documental no estás firmando la realidad
haces un recorte de la realidad que se
diferencia mucho de la ficción acá es
todo lo que pasó frente a la cámara fue
lo que estaba pasando para el mundo
ahora a lo largo de este documental de
tu historia logrando con mujeres de
distintas generaciones pero también de
distintos países no todas ellas han
luchado en contextos muy diferentes que
las une además del activismo por la
despenalización y la legalización del
aborto
sin duda las
11 mundo
diseñado para nosotros los varones las
une esa desigualdad no donde hoy en la
actualidad donde se creía que el derecho
al aborto estaba conquistado en un país
como eeuu
volvió para atrás no a los derechos de
la educación sexual integral siguen
estando en discusión y en conflicto
entonces es a mi generación nos tocó
vivir y ser testigos de una rebeldía y
una rabia una rabia de qué son los
feminismos de ahora por así decirlo
entonces
yo considero que eso las uniones esa
desigualdad no había la verdad que hoy
no hay no hay no hay un movimiento
como el feminismo que logre tejer tantas
redes cuando yo me contacte con la
activista de bolivia la activista en
colombia se conocían intercambiando
mails herramientas entonces te das
cuenta que es una red que se ha tejido a
partir del dolor y la rabia y la ha
hecho muy sólida y yo estoy muy
convencido de que los cambios que
necesita nuestra sociedad van a venir de
la mano del feminismo y de las
diversidades
todo lo que está el margen de lo que ya
fue normado y de la espero norma ángel
bueno voy a preguntarte algo sobre lo
que recién acaba de hacer referencia no
porque la marea verde que vos conocés
muy de cerca llegó a eeuu no por la
decisión de la corte suprema que terminó
con el derecho federal al aborto la
lucha y la manera que el movimiento de
mujeres inspira atraviesa todo tu
documental en este sentido crees que
podría ser un instrumento de importancia
más para quienes luchan en otros lugares
oye
en todo caso no es la película en todo
caso es el móvil es la marea verde claro
latinoamericana porque esto ya que dicha
ya cruzó la frontera ya ya pasó el río
de la plata y la película es una
observadora y si la película es puede
ser usada de vehículo para que esas
herramientas de activismo sistema show
tú ya muy agradecido y sepan la
audiencia no dude en contactarme ángel
giovanni hoyos vista gran marea verde
film y contactarnos y la película
llegará a donde tenga que llegar y quien
esté dispuesto a proyectarla ya
compartirla es una película que se hizo
colectivamente con un equipo colectivo
con una productora que ese que se
arriesgó y se hizo la película y es para
eso para inspirar otras cosas porque al
fin y al cabo lo que cuenta la película
es la lucha así como es la lucha por
conquistar el derecho al aborto hay
muchas luchas por venideras
y es una ley universal y creo que en ese
caso en ese sentido la película logra
darte algo muy importante es la
constancia no las mujeres durante más de
20 años exigieron el derecho al aborto
legal seguro y gratuita y lo
conquistaron y lo están defendiendo en
argentina
absolutamente y hay que defenderlo
porque bueno el caso de eeuu así lo
demuestra no nada está garantizado
ángel que dijo realizar este documental
más allá de lo profesional y como
cineasta me refiero
no volvería a ser una película sobre el
aborto
eso primero por sentido porque de chad
esa ya está esa pregunta no porque he
hecho haciendo una película sobre el
aborto me dejó mucha experiencia y sobre
todo saber que la importancia de los
procesos
hecho durante seis años hoy ya ya se
están cumpliendo siete años pero habla
desde el año de los estrenos pero entre
seis años me aventuré a hacer una
película imposible donde todas las
puertas a los productores que me acerqué
hablarles del proyecto les parecía que
no tenía sentido y me di cuenta que vale
la pena soñar y que parte del
capitalismo y este mundo que vivimos tan
agónico lleva a una velocidad
desesperada nos están quitando
la libertad de soñar y que si el sueño
era hacer una película hay que cumplirlo
teniendo siendo consciente de lo que es
tu sueño y si el sueño es creer de que
puede haber un mundo mejor y ahí en la
residencia eso mejor es la película ser
constante y soñar soñar como que nos es
válido soñar y nos merecemos soñar con
un mundo mejor más igualitario con más
oportunidades
y bueno como dice ahora la
vicepresidente de colombia para vivir
sabroso
ángel giovanni hoyos muchísimas gracias
por tu presencia en la entrevista de
france 24 disponibles y un placer
dialogar contigo realmente gracias por
la invitación y bueno espero verles
pronto y seguir compartiendo nuevas
aventuras y recomendamos por supuesto to
be comentar a toda nuestra audiencia
gracias una vez más y en nuestra
audiencia le invitamos a que sigan
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
france24 punto com sigan junto a
nosotros
[Música]